now to a story you will see only on cbs
mornings members of congress are calling
on the department of defense to do more
to help civilians who have gotten
gigantic medical bills for emergency
treatment at u.s military facilities the
news comes from a nonpartisan government
report that says even though many of
those bills could be reduced or even
waived the department of defense almost
never does that according to the report
67 percent of civilians two-thirds who
received treatment did not have
insurance at the time consumer
investigative correspondent anna werner
has been looking into this for a long
time more than a year in fact anna good
morning
good morning tony and i'm sure you
remember we introduced you to a man
named alexis hernandez he was burned all
over his body got emergency treatment at
a specialized burn unit in at a military
center in texas then got a massive bill
well now some members of congress are
asking why so many civilians are
continuing to get those high bills for
their emergency treatment at military
centers
it looks like the military has been
resistant to reducing these bills for
civilian patients that's democratic
representative joaquin castro from san
antonio reacting to this government
report it found the department of
defense rarely provides financial relief
to civilians facing large bills for
emergency treatment received at military
centers
in april last year we told you the story
of alexis hernandez who spent seven
months at a texas military hospital burn
unit after being injured in an explosion
he endured 19 surgeries before being
released later the u.s government sent
him this bill saying he owed the u.s
treasury 1.7 million dollars what did
you think when you saw this letter
completely
completely hopeless legislation passed
in 2020 gave the military the power as
of last year to reduce or waive those
bills but a year later the government
accountability office report finds that
rarely happens of nearly 27 thousand
civilian medical debt cases the gao
reviewed from a five-year period only .1
percent were reduced just 32 cases it
further said while dod has options to
provide financial relief it does not
consistently inform patients about them
now representative castro and senator
elizabeth warren in a letter to the
secretary of defense are demanding
answers as to why there's a benefit
to the military by them being able to
treat these patients so what the
military should do is work with private
insurers but also work with patients to
reduce these bills and to get rid of
exorbitant or extraordinary costs
that patients are being built with
the department of defense did not
comment on the report the treasury
department told us it's working with the
department of defense to make sure that
its debt collection referrals are
are accurate i should say and they say
they take these recommendations
seriously but representative castro says
all this may lead to a mandate for them
to either lower or waive these bills
he's now working on legislation on that
by the way we wanted to tell you how
alexis hernandez is doing now remember
he was burned all over his body he tells
me he has had 29 surgeries to date now
however
at the time of his explosion he was
going to go to medical school guess what
he is now in medical school in puerto
rico
and doing very well and very happy to be
there so nate a great update on alexis
now
that is a great update awesome for him
anna thank you